I just got home from seeing Black
Panther and it was super awesome to see
a solo movie on him and it was great
watching the story of Black Panther kill
monger and we'll condo on screen I don't
want to say too much about it because I
don't want to give any more spoilers
away than I have to but this is a
post-credits scene explanation video so
unfortunately I'll have to divulge some
spoilers about the movie
okay so first post-credit scene we see
Chawla get up in front of the entire
United Nations with Nakia and Ikoyi
behind him and also Evert Ross in the
crowd watching him as well he gets to
the podium and states that he is to
chala king of Wakanda and for the first
time in history what Connor will be
sharing its knowledge and resources with
the rest of the world from there he
begins to talk about how the world must
come together and how they must find a
way to look after one another as if they
were one single tribe after that a
snooty politician from a country whose
name they don't tell us asked him with
all due respect King T'Challa what can a
nation of farmers have to offer the rest
of the world
T'Challa then just smiles knowing that
Wakanda is the most technologically
advanced nation in the world and it
shows Nakia Ikoyi and Everett Ross
smiling as well okay so what does this
mean throughout the movie several
characters including Black Panther talk
about whether it is right or wrong for
what Conda to stay hidden
and only worry about protecting
themselves and not the rest of the world
towards the end of the movie when
Chautala is talking with all the
previous kings and black panthers he
announces that they were all wrong for
not helping the world which leads them
to giving the speech to the United
Nations
so what Conda under King touch Allah's
rule is basically going to share their
technology with the world and their
vibranium what this really could lead us
into is the next Avengers movie infinity
war an infinity war the Avengers will
face Thanos one of Marvel's biggest
baddest villains ever they're going to
need every inch of help they can get if
they even want to stand a chance against
Thanos vibranium could lead to advances
in Iron Man suit which will play a
crucial part in defeating Thanos and if
his suits get in an upgrade spider-man
suit will be getting one as well it
could lead to highly advanced weaponry
for Hawkeye and black widow and let's
face it they need it and let's not
forget that Tony Stark and Bruce Banner
are geniuses so we know that they will
be able to get everything they can from
vibranium and the tech
ecology second post credit scene 3
Wakanda and children are in at what
Condon huh standing over someone while
whispering to each other the person
wakes up and the children run outside
and talked up two challahs sister Jerry
the person comes out and guess who it is
that's right good old Bucky and still
only with one arm once he comes out sure
he asked him how he's doing and he says
good thank you
then she says come much more for you to
learn but the most interesting part is
that when he comes out of the hut the
wakandan children start yelling white
woof white wolf is actually a character
in Marvel Comics but in Marvel Comics
the character's name is hunter
Hunter is actually two challahs adopted
brother King to Chaka to come in after
his parents died in a plane crash in
Wakanda eventually when he's older King
to Chaka appoints him leader of Oakland
a secret police the dogs of war and the
comics went to chala becomes king he
actually dismantles the secret police
and white wolf becomes a villain for a
moment in the comics eventually though
him into Chaka become allies now I don't
actually think this is a setup for a new
villain and black panther - for starters
we know that Bucky will be in Avengers
infinity war and he'll be fighting aside
Captain America also the fact that -
Chaka is who appointed White Wolf ahead
of the secret police and - Chaka is
already dead I actually see them forging
two characters into one here I think
Bucky will most likely be some kind of
authority in Wakanda and I think we'll
transition from him being the Winter
Soldier to him being white woof seeing
as how somewhat Condon's are already
calling him that it will be interesting
to see how this particular story pans
out in Avengers infinity war and the
second Black Panther movie so those are
the two post credits scenes in black
panther I hope I didn't spoil too much
of it and I hope this gets you excited
for Avengers infinity war coming out
what did you think of Black Panther let
me know in the comments below and be
sure to drop a like and subscribe to my
channel for everything Black Panther
Avengers infinity war and all things
Marvel and superhero thank you so much
for watching and have a great day